>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mark Dimunation:
Welcome everybody
to another Thursday at three.
I'm, glad to see so
many people here.
We have a real treat
instore for us today.
I was familiar with Casey Gardner's
work before I actually met her
at Kodak's, but meeting her at
Kodak's just sealed the deal.
She's -- not only does she do
smart, creative, accessible books,
artists books or press
books, she has a sense
of humor, a political viewpoint.
A design esthetic that's
sometimes Jetson,
sometimes mid-century,
sometimes modern.
All of that happens in five minutes
of the conversation with her.
And we're going to get even
more of that with her today.
So, I'm really thrilled to have
Casey come all the way from Berkley
to share some of her
insights about her books
and what she's doing with them.
We have some of her materials
as we usually do on the table.,
and afterwards we'll be
happy to show them to you
and you can feel free to ask Casey
whatever questions you would like.
Casey asked me to have you remind
her that if she turns to you
and freezes, someone just
needs to yell, "Breath."
And with that of a way of
introducing, Casey Gardner.
[ Applause ]
>> Casey Gardner: Thank you so much.
All right.
So, I have a talk written,
and I will try not to read it,
but chances are I will be reading
it, but it's written from the heart.
So, all right.
So, this is a model of the
beginning of our universe
that was 13.8 billion years ago.
To me, this image is
pure visual poetry.
According to this model, everything
that exists in our universe,
every star and planet that composes
us in our lives, all matter,
was within an infinitely single,
tiny point, a so-called singularity.
Then, all that energy suddenly
expanded into the void and inflated,
opening up space, and
eventually coalescing
into galaxies, everything.
I'm moved by all these forces
conspiring to time and a space
where our lives are possible.
Science and art have intersections.
Both are trying to understand
how and why we are here.
Nothing, even The Big
Bang is conclusive.
So, I have a story for you,
and I'm telling you this story,
because it happened here in D.C.
And because it marks the beginning
of my long, slow journey
to becoming an artist.
And because it also
explains part of my psyche.
So, one day, I was walking down
Pennsylvania Avenue with thousands
of other enthusiastic ardent
vociferously enraged people.
The streets were barricaded, it
was 1992, and Planned Parenthood
versus Casey was before
The Supreme Court.
The provisions of Rogue v
Wade were being challenged.
We marchers were voicing our support
for women's' reproductive rights.
I was there with my
family and friends,
and zillion of my mother's
activist friends.
We made our way down
Pennsylvania Avenue, and I listened
to my mother regale those
around her with a story
of her own pro Roe
V Wade desperation.
It was the early 60s, she'd
had her first baby at 18,
and the next one came 11
months later, now at 20,
the third was on its way.
Things were not good at home,
and this one-time high school
student librarian was feeling lost
in despair, wretchedly stupid, and
finding herself pregnant again.
She desperately did
not want another child.
Telling this tale years
later on Pennsylvania Avenue,
my mother has many years as
political activist and feminist
under her belt, and she warms
to her count illustrating
the plight of all women.
She dramatically and graphically
discloses the various acts she was
forced to resort to in attempts
to abort her unwanted fetus.
When she finally scraped
together the means to pay
for a back-alley abortion, a very
risky procedure in those days,
she was too far along for the
pregnancy to be terminated.
We marchers all listened spell
bounded righteous outrage,
as we walked on the pavement
lifting our pro-choice signs.
In that moment, I did a bit of
calculation, I was her third child,
and it dawned on me that I
was the one in her belly.
That moment on Pennsylvania
Avenue was a crisis for me,
or just in the political
and personal sense,
but of my very existence.
I marched along trying to reconcile
my supportive freedom and choice,
knowing it meant I would not exist.
Eventually, I came into the world
at Georgetown University
Hospital as Casey Sullivan.
And so, yes, I'm very happy to be
here today, alive in this world
with all of its precariousness,
and where something can
be created from nothing.
So, after I was born here we -- my
family moved to Columbia, Maryland.
And when I was ten, we
moved to Aspen, Colorado.
And there, in the public school
system, I was in a program
that took us into the wilderness.
So, I didn't spend that much time in
the classroom, but I learned a lot
of mountaineering skills
and I spent a lot
of time sleeping under the stars.
So, the mountains really
came to define me there.
And after that, I lived in Colorado
until I was 35, and then I moved
to California, and
now I live in Berkley
about 50 yards from
a major fault line.
In preparing this talk, I identified
six words that guide me in my work,
they are feeling, beauty, matter,
motion, wonder, and my favorite word
in the human language, why?
These words motivate all
my work, but for this talk,
I'll highlight them one at a
time with examples of my books.
For my -- my first two
words come from this quote
from the photographer Dorothea
Lange, she found beauty and dignity
in the faces of people
in the Depression.
This sits on the windowsill
of my studio.
My books usually take a year or
two to make, so before I embark
on a project, I have to make
sure I feel deeply about it.
What drives my interests
is certainly intellectual,
but the emotional undercurrents and
their mystery really propel my work.
And so, my first word is feeling.
Feeling plays a role
throughout making the work.
I'm working along on my
trajectory and it comes --
out of nowhere a feeling comes.
I try to ignore it.
It's vague, uncertain, outlandish,
but it whispers, "What
if you tried this?
What if this actually means that?
And I think, but that's a
whole new door to go through,
I have no intention going there.
I didn't even know such a door
was possible or even existed,
and I try to continue on my course.
Feeling is totally irrational, it's
not interested in being efficient
or being the direct course.
I think feeling comes from
this space where the body
and the mind meet, maybe we
call it instinct or intuition.
So, eventually, I listen
to it and I open the door.
This is my most recent book,
I finished it in February,
it's called the Gravity Series.
These three books -- all of my
books are letter pressed printed,
so I'll try -- I don't
need to repeat that.
These three books are clothed bound,
and they're hung -- suspended in --
by magnets in the carrying case.
In many ways, this is my most
personal book, in that I opened
up my own experiences to
investigate my topic, gravity.
This series of books reckons with
gravity as a universal, and yet,
very personal phenomenon,
holding everything
in perpetual motion
and relationship.
Each of these books uses gravity
as a metaphor for love in terms
of falling, climbing and orbiting.
So finally tuned is gravity,
that if its quantity had been
even infinitesimally altered,
our universe as we know
it could not have emerged,
and life would not exist.
This fine tuning can actually
be calculated, physicists --
cosmologists and phs -- physicists
calculate it to 10 to the minus 122.
I'm thinking that's
122 zeros, right?
That's just an in -- it's
incredible what that --
how finally tuned the
workings of our universe are.
Though gravity is the weakest
of the four universal forces,
it's strong enough to hold galaxies
together, and precise enough
to give each one of us weight
and be held here on earth.
Each book explores how we live with
influences we cannot always control,
but rely upon forces
we cannot see but feel.
What is this unseen power that
like love, is vital to life?
I'll take you through
each of the three books.
I'm starting with this
one, All there is,
because it's how the
whole series started.
I was trying to think one day
about what I could believe
in unequivocally, what
really, truly existed?
And I came to gravity and I
thought, that's all there is,
that's all there is,
that's all there is.
And I just thought, I loved how
it could be, that's all there is,
and that's all there is, gravity.
So, that was the beginning
of this project.
This book in particular is about
climbing, it's also about trust
and finding your own
center of gravity
as you move your weight
upward on rock.
Meanwhile, you're putting
your life in the hands
of your partner who's belaying you,
[inaudible] that person
with your weight.
So, this spread is
about a crux of a climb.
And I wanted to say, so climbing --
I don't know if there's
any climbers here?
There's a spelunker here.
>> A caver.
>> Casey Gardner: A caver.
Oh, that's a difference.
>> A caver is as risky
as spelunkers.
[ Laughter ]
>> Casey Gardner: So --
>> Sorry.
>> Casey Gardner: I could never
be a caver, but I tried it.
So, anyway, when you're
climbing a crux
of a climb is the most
difficult part of a climb,
and there's slab climbing.
And when you're on a slab,
you are relying on friction
to sort of get you to move.
And the best way to move is to sort
of, instead of clinging to the rock,
to pull away from the rock,
and that gives your --
puts the anchor into your feet.
So, you're sort of finding
your way through gravity,
and it's a little bit
counterintuitive.
And I think in all these
different ways, like right now,
we're having this relationship
with the center of the earth.
We have our own relationship
with the earth
in gravity, through gravity.
And in these sports, whether it's
skiing, or climbing, or surfing.
Surfing I have less of a good
relationship with gravity.
We're finding out where
our own centers are,
and that's happening all the time,
and I just think that's fascinating.
it's about being in the
center of the earth, and so,
all the time we're in gravity.
And this relationship with --
supposedly, everything in the
universe has a relationship
with everything else that
has mass through gravity.
I just love this stuff.
So -- so, these figures,
just a little bit on process,
I drew with a brush and ink,
and then I scanned
them into my computer.
And anything I can draw, I
can scan into my computer
and create into a plate to print.
At the end of the book is a map
of a climb I did with a partner.
We grappled with risk and
trust, and here I printed some
of the words marking our root
as we were tethered together.
The next book is How to Fall.
It's about falling in love.
No, no -- can you guys read that?
>> Crowd: Mm-hmm.
>> Casey Gardner: Okay.
One day I was living my
perfectly lovely life,
and working in a book
store when someone walked
through the door, and
I fell for him.
And I eventually fell out
of line, fell to my knees,
and my lovely life
fell to the wayside.
When I was 18, I married a
professional ski racer, now at 28,
I didn't think I was looking
to fall for anyone, but, well,
I fell head over heels,
I fell from grace.
Things fell a part, but
mostly I fell in love.
Eventually, my life fell back
together, that's a different book.
How do we live with these unseen
forces that influence our lives?
Sometimes the line between
flying and falling isn't clear.
A star close enough
is about orbiting.
This book includes a volvelle, which
spins through the various points
and paths of two bodies orbiting
each other in relationship.
You guys know what a
volvelle is, right?
This is a sophisticated audience.
The opening page of the book,
the verso, left page reads,
"Speaking of space as lovers
do", then on the recto it reads,
"He says nothing's sacred anymore,
she says everything is,
he says same thing."
In orbits, two mutually attracted
bodies revolve around a joint center
of mass located in the
space between them.
In relationships, two bodies move
closer together and further apart
as they mediate their distance
creating their own orbit.
Meanwhile, our earth is
gravitationally bound
in the most propitious
orbit around our son,
making it just the right distance
to receive its life giving energy.
Often, I feel super unsophisticated
because of my sense of wonder.
So, here I'm writing this
grandiloquent poem speaking to a guy
about how fantastic
everything is, how amazing it is
that the world even exists, and that
the sun is so perfectly situated
for us to make peach pie,
and he is exasperated.
Now I'll move on to
my next word, beauty.
So, Lange's phrase is, "Beauty
appears when one feels deeply."
I come to book art
through my love of books,
they have made me who I am.
Without books, without
libraries, I would have been lost.
Growing up, I vas an avid reader,
in books I learned to see the world.
From this book Harriet the Spy,
I discovered a way of looking
and relating to the world around me.
From this book I learned
to keep a journal,
which was the beginning
of my writing life.
I learned about imagination
and possibility from books,
how whole worlds could
be created in pages.
I also learned about
beauty from books.
I remember spending a lot of time
gazing at the covers of books.
I would imagine entering into
the realms they illustrated.
I still have a few of my
childhood books, you can tell,
look at the price on that.
This is one of my very favorites,
and the cover remains
in my imagination.
Much of my sense of beauty comes
from those magical
moments gazing into books.
I made this book Cartographical
Incantations in 2015.
Its pages are letter pressed and
digitally printed and it's bound
into an accordion structure.
Structure, that's a toughie
for me, structure, okay.
I also find beauty in
maps, globes , and atlases.
In the public library in Amsterdam,
up several flights of stairs,
I found a treasure trove of
atlases, I was in heaven.
One book held 17th century maps
from the seafaring Dutch
explorers and merchants.
I snapped some photos from my phone,
and later I used these
images in these books.
I only had fragments of the maps,
I put them into Adobe Illustrator.
And because I was thinking
about hinges at the time,
I reflected them, and I found that
I could make shapes with them.
Each spread has on the verso a
history of cartography starting
with the map from the 7th
Century B.C. Babylonians.
This spread shows a
Medieval T.O. map,
then on right is a poem
an incantation I wrote
about taking journeys or
finding your way in the world.
As I played with the maps,
beauty again appeared.
I found I could create patterns.
My books always had
various narrative roots
or patterns offering
the reader opportunities
to chart their own
course through the pages.
Here on the left, verso, is the
instruction in using a compass
in the wilderness, on the right
is an incantation, I'll read it.
Wayfair's Incantation
for finding your space.
"Here you are, still you are here?
Here you are still,
are you still here?
You are still here, do
not abandon yourself."
The other side of the
folios is this narrative,
another narrative pathway.
It's a traveler's tale of chance
and choice, those words chance
and choice come up
a lot in my books.
Chance. This reads, "Perhaps you
are given a map, perhaps not."
This line reads, "Perhaps that is
you disappearing down the stairway
and into the dark, your feet
echoing off of the glistening road."
A few years earlier, in Matter,
Anti-Matter and So Forth,
I'd written this line,
just that one sentence,
and I always wondered
where that came from.
So, here in this book I
wrote a story about it.
This map forms the shape
of our entrance into world.
It reads, "Just to See
What Might Happen."
My next word is matter.
I'm thinking about
this word all the time.
Not just in terms of
what is significant,
meaning what matters,
but what has meaning.
Also, in the cosmological aspect
of matter transforming into energy,
and energy transforming into matter.
It was making this book, Matter,
Anti-Matter and So Forth in 2013
that I learned that matter and
energy were interchangeable.
I remember walking down
the street one day,
and I realized I was looking
at the world and existence
in a radically different way.
Before making this
book, my foundations
of reality were mostly
philosophical.
Studying Quantum Physics,
what I could understand of it
and Asper Physics, my sense of life
on earth became more
objectively elemental.
The title of this book refers
to a time after the Big Bang
when a small preponderance of matter
over anti-matter was produced.
None of the physicists understands
where this asymmetry comes from,
I found that out from my neighbor.
So, a year of ago, a particle
physicists moved in next door.
[ Laughter ]
I couldn't believe it.
She does tons of research,
she researches gluons.
And so, we over resorting -- sorting
our recycling we might be talking
about gluons and how
they'll -- let's see.
The gluons, they're actually
using the strong nuclear force
to hold the atom together.
So, yeah, I learned
that from her, gluons.
Okay. Yeah, Berkley.
Without this asymmetry, matter and
anti-matter would have continued
to annihilate each other, and
nothing could have emerged.
This book is a series
of seven folios wrapped
in a map of the universe.
The folios follow the story
of two travelers in space.
One traveler from earth
is on a quest
for what truly matters
in the universe.
Along the way, she meets a
character from outer space.
He is looking for a new dimension
that can only be revealed
to him by an earthling.
We follow their journey as they
move through various realms
of cosmic discovery, each folio
has a focus of investigation.
This slide shows the slides of
science, constellations, and light.
The layered transparencies
are intergalactic artifacts
from the transparent universe.
This represents a time
after the Big Bang
when the universe was transparent,
and light could move freely.
And for these images, I took --
they were photos from
the Monterey Aquarium,
they looked sort of cosmic.
So, yeah, those are like
jelly fish in there.
I love aquariums too, I was in the
Natural History Museum yesterday.
Here, the time folio is on the left
and the gravity folio
is on the right.
There's a moment in the time folio
where the two characters
find themselves at the end --
in the Interstitial
Interstellar cafe.
Here, they share coffee from
luminaries plucked from divergent,
historical, and literary eras.
So, Galileo chats with Van Gogh,
and Machiavelli meets Rosa Parks.
On the back of each photo
is a mission dispatch.
This gives me -- this gave me
space to write what I was learning
of the natural forces and
phenomenon of the cosmos.
There's a story in the Infinity
folio where one of the --
where the character says she
sees sculpture, and she asks --
it's an Infinity sculpture.
She asks her mother what it is,
and her mother replies, "Love."
This actually is a memory
that I had from being outside
of the Air and Space Museum.
So, when I was growing up,
there was an Infinity sculpture,
and it was silver, and
it spun around slowly.
>> Mark Dimunation:
It's still there.
>> Casey Gardner: It's still there?
Because I was there
yesterday, and I thought,
did Infinity become obsolete?
It wasn't there.
No, I mean, so I remember
-- so, I said, --
we were, the three of
us kids were there,
and we asked my mom
what infinity was.
So, parents must have
these amazing moments.
And so, my mom goes,
"Something that lasts forever."
And we're like, what lasts forever?
And she said love, so I thought
that was -- and that stayed with me,
but I did look for that
sculpture yesterday,
and maybe I just didn't
go in the right entrance.
And then I stood in front of
the Gemini and Mercury capsules.
Oh my gosh, that was -- I wept.
For some reason they
were very moving to me,
thinking of humans in those.
So, meanwhile -- hmm.
So, when I heard I was going to
do this talk, I asked my mother
to send me pictures
of us kids in D.C.
when we were young,
and she sent this gem.
So, I'm pretty sure that this
is the Infinity sculpture,
that's the plinth in any case.
So, that's -- we loved
going to the Smithsonian
when I was growing up,
my mother took us often.
So, we always called it the
Smithsonian, but it's like now,
it's this whole constellations of
museums, and for me it was the Air
and Space Museum, and the
Natural History Museum,
that's where we went.
So, that's my brother John in the
Chucks, my sister in the red dress,
and that's me not liking my
shoes in the white tights.
I'm pretty sure that's why
I had that look on my face.
Because I loved, it was just total
joy going to the Smithsonian.
So, this might be a good time
I can show you a little bit
about how I make books.
This is my printing studio.
It's a 10 by 12 foot shed
that's in our backyard.
So, I live like, close
to the Berkley campus,
my husband's a Professor
of Economics at Berkley.
Just, I keep saying we, and so,
I thought I'd give you
the other part of the we.
So, this -- you can see my
Vandercook , it's a Vandercook 4.
Vandercooks were printing presses
that newspapers used for proofing.
This one is from the 1950s, and in
the back, there's a type cabinet
with wood and metal type.
There's a furniture cabinet,
and here is a book press,
because I also do binding
in there, not just printing.
This is a picture of casing in All
There Is, and I make tons of notes
when I'm doing production,
because I don't seem
to think when I'm in production.
And so, this one, you can
see I have north, north.
All this north stuff, it's because
there's 18 magnets in that book,
and I had to keep the polarities of
north, south straight all the time.
And then, like, I'm
just constantly --
like, I just go into a
different mode in production.
And so, I just have notes of,
don't do that, be careful!
And so -- and a lot of the --
what I do is in my body memory.
I don't seem to be rational
when I'm binding books,
even though it's super -- I --
for all the different bindings it
takes a lot of MAC heads to figure
out how the materials interact.
This is a gratifying moment.
So, this is part of my
addition of the Gravity series.
Usually, my additions are
30 to 50, and this probably,
maybe like, 20 or something.
So, I just -- ahh, that --
when I took that picture,
it was a really nice feeling.
So -- but I like production,
I usually --
some people they don't do
all their books when they --
they don't produce all their books
after they get finished with them,
but I do, because of
the body memory.
I couldn't -- like Julie Chen keeps
notes of everything, and then she --
when she needs a book she makes it.
I don't think I could do that
really, so -- but she's Julie Chen.
This is my -- the other
place where I do my work,
this is inside of our house.
This is where I write, draw, work
on the computer, make MAC heads,
carve linoleum, cut paper, do
everything, print digitally.
Does everyone know how plate
making -- how plates are made?
Anything that you can put
into the computers, whether --
if you draw something, you can
scan it, put it into the computer.
And then, it gets --
you can make a file
that gets created into a negative.
And then, the negative
gets placed on polymer,
and where the light shines
through, the polymer rises up so
that you can create a relief plate.
So, anything that I can draw,
or create, like, creating
and design can be made into a plate.
>> Mark Dimunation: So,
that includes the figures
of the climbers?
>> Casey Gardner: Yes.
Yes, exactly.
So, I -- those were
done in brush, in ink.
Fifty-thousand of them until I
found the ones I liked, and then,
I scanned them in and turned
them into a vector file,
so that it's a true black.
And then, that gets turned
into a negative, and then,
where the negative -- where the
white light can get through,
photo polymer.
>> Mark Dimunation: Because
they look like linocuts.
>> Casey Gardner: Oh,
yeah, I do linocuts too.
A lot of the printing in How
to Follow is linocut,
all of it, basically.
Yeah, in fact, when
you say back there,
that's a piece of linoleum
on my press.
That's a -- yeah, you can see
that, I really like linoleum.
That was -- that's
kind of a new thing
in the past couple years for me.
>>[inaudible] American
History Museum.
>> Casey Gardner: Thank you.
I like that, real -- the
American History Museum?
>> Yeah.
>> Didn't it say, Art
and Technology, or -- >
>> It's [inaudible] 1968.
>> Casey Gardner: Right.
>> And it's basically [inaudible].
>> Casey Gardner: Is that true?
Right on. But I must
have gone to -- okay.
Thank god, your here.
Very similitude to
everything, to me.
I don't want to lead
you guys a stray.
So, one more thing I wanted
to say about this room,
in the middle of the slide
next to the Periodic Table
of Elements is the
model for my book,
Body of Inquiry, the
Anatomical Model.
So, I -- I'll talk
about that book later.
This is an example of
how I begin my work,
such a perfect example of my brain.
So, actually it would be more --
if it were my brain, it'd be --
it wouldn't be written like that,
in fact, I have stuff like that.
So, what happens is, I'll be reading
books and I'll just take notes,
and that way I can sort of pay
attention to what interests me,
and then, see relationships.
And all throughout the
process that I'm working,
I'm constantly doing this, because I
might be just trying to write like,
two lines, and then I
start reading about it.
And then, it ends up being,
you know, like this big --
and I usually take really
big pieces of paper,
and -- yeah, to find words.
Words. This is an example of a
sketch, this is a project that --
for a print I did called the
Multiverse Beta-gerse[phonetic].
And at this point when I'm
sketching it's pretty fun,
because I don't have
to make much sense.
It's a weird thing,
because it's a fun moment,
because it's really free.
But at the same time, I don't
really know where I'm going.
So, there's this little
bit of like, whoa, whoa,
like speaking of not really
knowing where you are in gravity.
So, that's what that looks like.
My next word is motion.
One of the things that I love about
print making is the constant motion.
Sometimes the rhythm of working
on the press feels like a dance.
Also, because books
are physical objects,
I like to consider the
reader being in motion
as they move thorough my books.
I'm drawn to images
of women as trees.
When I saw Bernini's 17th
century marble sculpture of Daphne
and Apollo in the Borghese
Gallery in Rome, I stood staring
at it for a very long time.
Just trying to see and feel how he
made marble into flesh, and then,
see the precise moment
when the flesh became bark.
I was wondering at
such beauty baroque
and elegant for such a tragic fate.
For decades I've been collecting
images of women as trees.
For a person who love freedom
and motion as much as I do,
I'm confounded by interests
in something rooted.
I made this book, Threshold
in 2012, it's about moving
through transformation
and creating change.
The cover of the book is
a poem about thresholds.
"Marking passage, the
framework of conception,
on the verge of where the
end becomes the beginning.
The shape like a doorway to open."
The form and content of this
book are closely related,
relying on each other for meaning.
I used a Turkish map fold, so when
the book opens, Daphne's hand opens
in the midst of leafing
and reaching for the sky.
In Ovid's Metamorphoses, we read
the nymph Daphne's passion was
to run free in the forest and hunt.
Then she becomes hunted herself.
she flees to escape
being ravaged by Apollo.
She runs to the river's edge
and cries out, "Change me",
and the god of the river turns her
into a tree rooted forever in place.
I read many translations
of this tale,
but I couldn't figure
out why a tree?
I do love trees, but it didn't
seem an apt metamorphoses
for someone like Daphne.
So, for this book, I wrote
my own version of this story.
Her determination to
remain free is inspiring,
yet her call for change
has an unexpected outcome,
as do many thresholds we cross.
The reader is asked to
put the book in motion,
turning it in order to read it.
Turning the book and looking at the
alcose, the reader moves in time
from day with the sun, and into
night with moon -- with the moon.
Turning to read each of the four
corners, which I considered, north,
south, east, and west, you find
the four Meta-muses of Flux,
I made up Greek names for them.
You started that.
This is my fourth and
fifth grade teacher
from Columbia Maryland,
John Sullivan.
And the -- he's the one
to whom the book Body
of Inquiries is dedicated to,
because I think I learned a lot
about curiosity from him.
But I remember you were the
one who introduced to us
about Greek roots, thank you.
So, each one of these
has a Greek name.
And Uthelia[Phonetic], in the
corner on the left is about vision
and ideas, she's in flight.
I ask -- I like the last line --
where it says she is bold
and her bones are light.
The next muse on the right
is Upraxia[Phonetic].
She's about planning
and calculating,
and realizing where ideas intersect
with reality in the material world.
Then the next muse on the
left is Utropia[Phonetic],
trop meaning change.
She is about the meandering path of
experimenting, and how responding
to the twists and turns
can form a surprising path.
Finally, the muse on the
right is Uthemia[Phonetic],
where everything comes together,
and the whole begins anew,
so the book keeps turning.
The border around the
book is printed
with a phrase, "There
is no fixed self.
We are all perpetually in motion
in our daily lives on our planet,
through the cosmos, at the
atomic and subatomic level.
We are essentially
motion, change is constant,
and there is no fixed self."
The next word is wonder.
The word wonder can go in
a few different directions.
It can be about curiosity, it
can be a happy awe of gratitude,
and it can be about
dumfounded incredulity.
In current events, I find
myself often in this last state.
I made this book Here say,
in 2012 with my friend
and former teacher Nance O'Banion.
I'd like to take a quick look
at this book, because I made --
though I made it five years ago,
it's come alive to me in a new way
with our current political
environment.
This book is about locating where we
are in a landscape of truth and lie.
It's about communication
and how we orient ourselves
in variable and interacting context.
The book opens to a map
with a spectrum to truth,
to half-truth, down the side.
And a spectrum of half-truth to
lie printed along the bottom.
The object is to see what happens
at the intersecting points.
The magnetized ear shape
structure holds volvelles spinning
with the variables of how one
hears and listens depending
on the shifting factors of who,
what, when, where, how, and why?
Turning the four different volvelles
creates different readings,
and offers many interpretations
of what we consider true.
This is an early volvelle,
I just liked it,
I saw it at the MSU Library, and
I thought I'd show it to you.
I really like volvelles,
they offer a dynamic way
of creating choice
and chance in a book.
He has slid his image
in at the last minute.
It's a piece that I am hoping
to finish in the next few weeks.
It's a project for my
multiverse beta curse[phonetic].
The yellow and green print on the
right is a map of the Big Bang,
I'm still working on that print.
But it has a caption that's
complete, it fits with this truth --
this theme of truth and wonder.
It reads, "What else might
be true", which works for me
in a cosmological sense, and also,
in this time of befuddling
political discourse.
My last word is why?
Moving on.
[ Laughter ]
This will be -- my final book
brings me to why, my favorite word.
I've come to believe this
is the most important word
that defines humans, and
make us uniquely creative.
Books are a place not only where
we can go to answer questions,
but for me, I found in books
a way to ask questions.
I made Why Go in 2010, it's the
last book I made as an art student
at the California School
College of the Arts.
it's about when I went into the
world alone, in the chronology
of my life it follows how to fall.
It took me a year of working two
jobs to save up for this trip.
I left my little town and
flew into the Pacific.
First, I rode my bike around
the islands of New Zealand.
Then I lived in a commune
there for a few months learning
about farming and permaculture.
Then into Indonesia and South-East
Asia where I found a monastery
in Thailand to learn about Buddhism.
Then I traveled for
several months in Vietnam,
Egypt, Israel, then home.
When I got home, I picked
up my life where I left it.
It wasn't until years
later that I had time
to ask myself what
it was I was looking
for in the world --
out there in the world?
Still figuring that out,
but what I can tell you is
that I found my voice in
making this book, in that,
my books could be questions.
So, this is the book that Betsy
Davids was my thesis advisor on?
Yeah. So, do you guys
know Betsy Davids?
She was a wonderful
of book art for me.
I made Body if Inquiry in 2011,
it's the first book I
made on hard school.
The subject of this book is the
anatomical model that she saw.
She inspired me to explore the
science and mystery of life.
I began first by reading about
her organs and how the body works.
Biology soon learned to -- led
to physics, and to physics,
it's a short leap into the cosmos.
I ordered her from an
Edmund Scientific catalog,
mail ordered her, so that tells
you how long I've had her.
So, for over 20 years she sat on
various bookshelves of my life.
Sometimes she's intact, the
carapace of her skin on,
but mostly she's open, her organs
in various places around my studio.
She maintains a particular
sung fwah[phonetic].
Looking in the distance,
never ruffled,
always a small simile
and every hair in place.
So, my husband's French,
and I had --
I said the word wrong for
a lot of -- saying Freud.
Because I've always said it the
way I would think to say it,
sometimes he corrects me.
She told me -- she holds
something transcendent
and secret despite her
openness and accessibility.
Over the years, I've referred to her
as Our Lady of Serene Evisceration.
There is something remote and
sacred, and yet incredibly exposed
and vulnerable about her.
I'd begun this book, but I
hadn't settled on a structure.
I wasn't sure what kind of space to
put her in, but then I was in Paris,
and I saw this image of Mary at the
Cluny not the image, the actual --
didn't see the image,
it was actually that.
That's the great thing
about museums.
So, this is what -- this
inspired the tryptic structure.
I didn't know like, what
kind of space to put her in.
And so, I realized that that was
just a moment of understanding that.
Like, I was thinking, does
she want to be in the forest,
like where is she going to live?
So, that was nice seeing that.
This is the other side of
the book, the instruments
on the outer panels are from 19th
and early 20th century
scientific catalogs that I found
in the Doe Library at UC Berkley.
These early laboratory instruments
represent our endeavors to measure
and quantify, and our
quest to understand things
that cannot be readily
apprehended by the senses.
The large panels explore atoms,
cells, and genetic structure.
The interior codex tells the
story of my anatomical model,
and investigates the permeable,
borderline between material
and immaterial in our
bodies and in our life.
These parts of the body
are all cut by hand.
The more resolve something is,
the longer the trail of failures
and experiments behind it.
I wanted the organs to be
accurate, and also happy
to be moved through and read.
I didn't want the reader to think
that it was too delicate
for their hands to open.
I enjoyed pairing the
actual functioning
of the organs with metaphor.
Here, the heart opens,
it is the body after all
that keeps us here on earth.
The perfect distance from our star
on a remote edge of the milky way,
one of 200 billion
galaxies in our universe.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mark.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: It is time
for Casey to take a few questions.
>> Casey Gardner: I answered
everything in my -- paper.
[ Chuckling ]
>> Casey Gardner: Yeah?
>> Do you have one of those machines
where you do the polymer plates,
or do you send them out,
or how does that -- ?
>> Casey Gardner: Some I
-- there's different like,
sometimes school have them
and I can access them.
Or the, now the San Francisco
Center of the Book has one,
but usually I'm really --
like, getting over to San
Francisco is hell now.
So, now I just sent
them out to Boxcar.
But, I'm going to having a
fellowship at Kala[phonetic]
and they have a plate maker.
So, it'll be kind of fun to be able
to have that instant gratification,
instead of a, you know,
I get the plate back.
So, yeah.
>> Mark Dimunation: And do
you leave that to images only,
or is some of your
[inaudible] typography also made
on the polymer plates?
>> Casey Gardner: Yeah,
that's all polymer, yeah.
And so, like, in that -- like, some
of that's my handwriting in there.
That was -- all my
books have something
where I don't know I can
do something, and so,
I want to experiment
with it in the book.
And that was like, for
some reason handwriting --
mixing handwriting and typography,
because I really love typography,
that's a big interest of mine.
So, I wanted to see how I could
mix my handwriting with typography.
And so, that was one
of the trajectories
of my -- of that book, yeah.
>> Just for chuckles sake,
there used to be a time
when if you wanted, you
could have type-high --
your signature type
high carved out of wood.
>> Casey Gardner: Oh, yeah, I
could imagine that happening.
Yeah, that'd be -- and I can print
on wood I can make it type high.
Yeah -- a wood plate,
because -- linoleum or wood.
Anything that I can make into relief
and make it .918, I can print on.
Yeah.
>> Mark Dimunation:
Is that your artwork?
>> Casey Gardner: It is.
So, the San Francisco for The
Book asked me to do a linoleum
for their steamroller printing.
So, that's three by -- that's
a three foot by three foot.
This is the carving of the linoleum.
>> Wow.
>> Casey Gardner: And
so, they lay the linoleum
on the street outside the San
Francisco Center of the Book,
and a big steam roller
comes along --
they put a piece of beautiful
Rives BFK down on it,
and the steam roller
comes along and prints it.
>> Wow.
>> Mark Dimunation:
They dampen the paper?
>> Casey Gardner: Yeah, they dampen
the paper, and then they have,
you know, like, all these people
with big ink rollers, you know,
kneeling down in the street.
>> Mark Dimunation: So, that
wasn't -- it wasn't on wood,
it was just on the linoleum.
>> Casey Gardner: Right, mm-hmm.
>> Mark Dimunation: So, it'll
add a little flexibility.
>> Casey Gardner: Good point.
Yeah, good point, and
they came out really well.
I wish I had one of those prints.
They -- it was a fundraiser, so
I didn't have -- get any, but --
>> Mark Dimunation: That
was a lot of carving.
>> Casey Gardner: It
was a lot of carving,
but my friend Macy
Chadwick came over,
and helped me do some
of the carving, yeah.
So, that was what really
got me into doing linoleum.
Like, I know how to do linoleum,
but I'd never really done that much
of it, and so, after that I
started using linoleum more.
That was a couple years
ago, so, yeah.
So, then this is -- let me see.
So, that's it just like,
after they printed it.
They hung it up on the -- outside
of the thing to let it dry.
So, that -- you can see it's
like they have these nice
little hang-up things.
So, yeah, that was it, that's
when I saw it for the first time.
I was like, o h, it worked out.
[ Laughter ]
>> Casey Gardner: But I really love,
I mean, you can see what I'm doing
with the women of the trees,
I'm trying to get her in motion
and also have her rooted.
And down in here in the
root sit says, "Oh, yes."
So --
>> Mark Dimunation: Kind of a
joke, no warning spots either.
>> No, they, I mean, they
know what they're doing.
They're not messing around, they're
-- they have some good printers
and the San Francisco
Center of the Book.
The guy's name is Chad,
and he's like --
he's just totally into
it that day, yeah.
So, they're -- it's actually going
on I think the one for this year
in the next week, yeah,
the big steam roller.
John?
>> John Sullivan: When did
you start learning to write?
Do you want to tell the class
[inaudible] here how you used
to sign your name?
>> Casey Gardner: Oh, I did!
I was thinking about that.
So, when I was in fourth
and fifth grade I used to --
>> John Sullivan: And the
other teachers wanted me
to beat her daily.
And I just saw something, I said,
I'm just going to let her go.
>> Casey Gardner: So,
I signed my name Casey,
and there was an exclamation
point, a smiley face, and a star.
And I never signed my name
without that like for years.
It didn't rally translate
when I moved to Colorado,
I tried it for a while, but it
didn't have the same resonance,
because I didn't have
a teacher like you.
No, but, yeah -- so, Casey --
but I should try that again.
Me and -- and then, Lori Martin,
I tried to get her to do it too.
>> Mark Dimunation:
On your business card.
>> Yeah, Casey, exclamation
point, smiley face, star.
>>Mark Dimunation: Yeah.
I think we'd take you
really seriously.
>> Casey Gardner: Yeah.
Well, luckily, I don't have to --
now I can just say, I'm an artist,
you don't have to take me seriously.
I can get -- I have such
impunity with that, so, yeah.
Anything else?
>> Mark Dimunation: Well,
would everyone join me
in thanking Casey once again today?
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov